buenas noticias para los chilenos
vacunados contra el hobbit 19 las
personas que hayan sido inmunizadas por
completo podrán gozar de un pase de
movilidad base que les dará la libertad
para desplazarse sin problemas tal y
como lo hacían antes de la pandemia así
lo dio a conocer el presidente sebastián
piñera esta semana implementaremos un
pase de movilidad que dará mayores grado
de libertad y de movilidad a las
personas que hayan completado
íntegramente su proceso de vacunación
con las dosis y los tiempos requeridos
el documento que entra en vigor este 26
de mayo consiste en un código qr que
podrá obtenerse de manera digital o
física y sólo se entregará 14 días
después de haber sido inmunizados por
completo sin embargo la medida ha
generado algunas críticas pues hay
quienes no la consideran oportunas la
implementación de un pase de movilidad
no es apropiada en este momento
epidemiológico en primer lugar porque
este va a aumentar la movilidad y con
esto el riesgo de que tengamos mayores
contagios en segundo lugar porque esto
puede generar una falsa sensación de
seguridad a las personas vacunadas que
tienen que mantener sus medidas
autocuidado de los casi 19 millones de
habitantes que tienen chile más de 17
millones han recibido al menos una dosis
de la vacuna mientras que más de 7
millones ya están vacunados por completo
esto representa poco más del 40 por
ciento de su población total